hi my name is Donna Dwyer welcome to the
point okay for the record I own a PC
PlayStation 4 Xbox one Wii U all bought
and paid for with my own hard-earned
cash let's get into this the point
season 3 episode 8 where are all the
kids console games where they at doh
hey guess what PC and console shooter
homefront the revolution has been
delayed until 2016 hey guess what ps4
exclusive uncharted for thieves and has
been delayed until 2016 hey guess what a
bunch of games you've played so far this
year were originally 2014 games that
were delayed until this year dying light
the order 1886 GTA online heists in fact
there are more delayed releases on the
way The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt
Arkham Knight Mad Max quantum break the
division and project cars that was
knocked back into 2015 but it's out next
we look at that it's been delayed so
we're gonna have to wait a bit longer to
play some of these games but that's fine
right except I don't really trust any
release dates anymore grand theft auto 5
PC release date has become the
drug-abusing cousin of gaming hey I'll
pay you back next week Danny now just
just give me another month I'll get you
the money don't be such a dick about it
I mean does anyone really think that the
vision is coming at this year you could
probably say the same thing about no man
sky will we see zelda on the Wii U in
2015 I doubt it Mario maker and
Miyamoto's project guard have already
slipped into the second half of this
year it just seems like now more than
ever we're getting these [__]
provisional release dates that then are
getting changed over and over and over
again before we actually see the games
and this is happening a lot more with
console games but maybe like it's a
technology thing I guess making games
for the PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
probably involves reeducate in your
workforce and getting used to new
processes so this whole thing happened
before in the last generation right
well except the little glance at the
lifecycle of the previous generation
makes for some uncomfortable viewing at
this stage in the previous generation
last year would have netted us Gears of
War Dead Rising Just Cause
Saints Row pray hitman blood money
Rockstar table-tennis a personal
favorite their Ghost Recon Advanced
Warfighter and the Elder Scrolls for
Oblivion ya bolivian was launched the
march following the consoles release the
basic equivalent of titanfall last year
but maybe that was just an unseasonable
code 12 months so let's look at the
following year 2007 the second year of
the 360s lifecycle and thus the relative
equivalent of the year were currently in
right now that was the year we played
Bioshock halo 3 portal skate rockband
uncharted and call of duty 4 modern
warfare I don't know maybe we were just
getting spoiled back then maybe I'm just
being a bit of a brat but there's a
market a difference between the quality
of some of the games we played in the
first two years of the previous console
generation 2 the games we've gotten to
play this time around could it have
something to do with the financial
climate we're in perhaps the loss of the
meteor developer has hit us harder than
we thought
those underhyped breakthrough games just
don't happen anymore so we put so much
more emphasis on the few large titles we
have to look forward to we overhyped
them which then makes the changing
release dates even more frustrating and
the failure is even harder to bear
especially as we're not seeing the same
type of game for evolution in the games
we're playing now I mean Gears of War is
kind of blase and all well and good now
but back in 2006 this rewrote the
rulebook the third person action design
and multiplayer shooting as well games
like Dead Rising and just caused at
these big open worlds you know before
these would have just been linear a
third-person experiences games like
portal Halo 3 and call of duty 4 modern
warfare I mean first person shooter
design has changed to Revit ibly since
those games came out can you really lay
the same praise on games like watchdogs
or infamous second son or Assassin's
Creed unity or Dragon Age Inquisition
titanfall Mordor and destiny are perhaps
the closest we've seen to true Avenue
last year and hopefully we'll see more
of it in 2015
maybe the division will do it perhaps
quantum break or The Witcher 3 or Metal
Gear Solid 5 or maybe even halo 5 I just
want to love my consoles again I want to
be excited by them what I remember about
loving consoles last generation was that
feeling that you were missing out on
something if you didn't own one there's
not much of that feeling right now
I don't know man maybe all these console
games slipping release dates all the
time just means that the big year for
consoles has slipped ahead a little bit
- I hope so my money's on 2016 for all
the big games but I mean we're gonna
have to have a bit of a blockbuster this
year at e3 three months and Counting
[Music]
yeah all right that's good that's a good
music video I like it